найстрашніше навіть не саме перенесення
А те що на судовому засіданні в нього
віднялися тоді руки і ноги я так розумію
через защемлення в хребті викликали
швидку йому зробили блокаду це екстрений
засіб після чого треба їхати в лікарню
натомість він до 9 години вечора був у
цій от клітці камері в судді без
належного медичного огляду і з того часу
його так до лікаря до лікарні і не
довезли це межує з катуваннями і ми
зараз готуємо запити і до повноваженого
з прав людини і до комітету з питань
прав людини також звернення до наших
міжнародних партнерів тому що будь-яка
людина заслуговує на гідне медичне
забезпечення Тим паче такий
герой-розвідник як Роман червінський і
вся офісна радь вони просто ж
намагаються його довести до повного
виснаження щоби він не говорив правди